- Did you make this sign?
- Yeah, I designed it.
- You shouldn't
have used this seal.
Okay, is this everyone?
- Yeah, this is the gang.
- So, as you know,
the reason I'm here,
is because one of
you was mugged.
I don't know who it
was, but I'm gonna
go ahead and guess, it was you.
- He's pointing
at you, obviously.
- I was mugged.
- I'm here to make you more
aware of your surroundings
on the outside,
and by doing that,
I'm gonna give each
of you your own
individual can of pepper spray,
which I will give you at
the end of the presentation,
which is now.
So, there any questions?
Yes.
(mumbles)
What?
- He said, "Are you a
real police officer?"
- Not anymore.
I was,
many years.
Ran over a teenager.
Now I do safety
demonstrations.
- Jesus.
- Is he alive?
- Yes, he's just, (gurgles)
- Are you okay?
- It's not about me, come up
and get your sprays, come on.
- It's not about him.
After the sprays, back to work.
(coughs)
- Can we leave now?
- He killed someone don't--
- I did not kill anyone.
- Well, that was the ninth time
I've been mugged this year.
- Oof.
- Oh my God.
What did the guy look like?
- Big.
Huge, like The Rock.
And not the cute, sweet little
Escape from Witch Mountain,
The Rock either, I'm
talkin' 'roided out,
balls the size of
raisins, The Rock.
- It's stupid that
we all had to be
at this presentation though.
I mean, I do MMA.
I shouldn't be here.
- You do MMA?
- Yeah.
I do it a lot actually.
- Oh, I'm sorry, I just
didn't know that MMA dudes
could be so...
- So what?
- Doughy?
- Aww...
- I'm not doughy,
I'm jacked bro.
- Down here.
- Stop it.
I didn't think I was
talkin' to frickin'
Joe Rogan over here.
- You the drivers?
- Yes.
- Yep.
- Mmhmm.
- [Police Officer] Alright,
I got pepper sprays
for you.
- Oh good.
- My hands are my pepper spray,
but I'll take one anyway.
- Alright, you guys know
how to use these things?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Where's the safety?
- Yep.
Oh my God!
- Oh my God.
- My eyeball!
- Oh no!
- Jesus Christ!
- I'm sorry dude, I'm sorry.
- You guys are morons.
- Thank you, officer.
- I'm losin'
peripheral vision here.
- [Rob] Can't see
that well anyway.
- You guys want a hit?
- Dude, a cop just walked away.
- Well, if we're gonna go
get this punk-ass bitch,
I'm gonna need to
get high first.
- What? Get who?
- The guy who mugged you.
Look, a cop just
issued us weapons.
We're depu-ties.
This is like Tombstone.
- No, that's not
a good idea man.
This guy had tear-drop
tattoos on his face,
and he knocked my
hat off my head.
- Aww.
- There's three of
us, and one of him.
Tombstone.
- I'm gonna surprise you guys,
and say I'm in.
(grunts)
I want to be Kurt
Russell in Tombstone.
- Well, you can't,
'cause I'm Kurt Russell.
- Oy...
- No,
you'd be more Val
Kilmer, because you guys
have the same type of body.
- Stop talking about my body.
- Well, you have a fatter body.
- I don't have, just
don't use the word fat,
just okay, it's bulky.
Just blood in, blood out.
Let's do this.
- Wait, who am I in Tombstone?
- Billy Zane.
- Yes.
- What is that?
Don't kiss.
- I'm in shock,
'cause it's getting worse now.
(techno music)
- This is dope.
My first real stakeout.
- I think we have to be in the
car for it to be a stakeout.
- Yeah, this is
more like stalking.
- It's not stalking.
Why is everyone so quick
to say that I stalk them?
- Who calls you a stalker?
- [Jon] You guys.
- Who else?
- I don't know, that girl Katie,
from the french fry truck
that I hooked up with,
who's apparently engaged
now, to the worst guy ever,
by the way.
(gasps)
- There he is.
- Let's get outta here.
- Yep.
- No, no, no, no.
Get out of the car,
this is the whole point.
Where is he, Mort?
- He's wearing my Pie Guys hat.
- [Rob] Dude, that
kid is like 15, maybe.
- I don't care how old he is,
he's 'bout to learn
not to fuck with us.
Let's go.
- This is bad.
- [Mort] I can't
believe you hooked up
with that girl from
the food truck.
- [Jon] Well, I kissed
her, but then she cried.
Pay back, bitch.
(yells)
- [Mort] That's my same eye!
- [Jon] Mort, get your wallet.
Rob, kick him!
- I'm not gonna kick
him, he's a kid!
- [Mort] I can't see anything!
- [Jon] Fine, I'll
do everything!
- Ah!
- Mort...
- [Jon] He doesn't have
a wallet, just some pogs.
- Oh, thank God, my pogs!
- Come on!
Come on!
- Aight, back to
the car, success!
(yells)
- Go, go, go, go, go!
- [Mort] Pie guys!
- Dude, come on!
- Okay.
(moans)
- [Mugger] I'm okay.
- [Jon] Fuck my keys,
my fuckin' keys.
- [Mort] What?
- [Jon] Shit!
- [Ron] Mort, come on!
- [Mort] I'm stuck.
- [Rob] Jon, what are you
doing, they're in the ignition!
- My keys!
- [Rob] They're in
the ignition, idiot!
Come on!
We just assaulted a
child in broad daylight!
Don't look at us!
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Mort, get your head
in the goddamn car.
- [Mort] Can we, I wanna...
(sighs)
- We gotta go this way.
- No, there's an
ice coffee place this way.
- Come on!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- My God, go!
- To us!
- I think we're bad people.
- Look, it's war, okay?
- How is it war?
- The important thing
is that we taught
a little scumbag a
lesson, and we're
never gonna have to
deal with him again.
- Hey, you little pussies!
- Oh fuck.
- You think it's funny
to pepper spray my son?
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slow your roll, Jane Kazmerack.
- [Mort] I think it's Kaczmarek.
- Just, A,
it's not my fault that you
raised Joffrey Lannister.
- Technically, he's a Barath--
- Just, B,
don't step unless
you're ready to dance,
'cause I have no problem--
- Is this your pepper spray?
- Yeah.
(yells)
- How does that feel?
(groans)
- You two,
take out your pepper spray.
- Let me be the first
to apolog--
- Take out your pepper spray!
(groans)
I want you to
spray each other in the face.
- Okay, lady, I'm
gonna level with you.
This is the third time--
- Do it now,
before I fuck your asses!
(groans)
(both scream)
- [Mort] We've been milf-hunted.
- [Jon] That's not
what that means!
(techno music)